The One Piece Manga just revealed the real
name of one of the Gorosei and I accidentally
used it to crack he hidden logic behind the
whole One Piece series.
Not only do we now know that the Gorosei are
5 of the 7 most powerful people in One Piece
and how they keep the world in balance, but
also what might have really happened between
the Gorosei, Imu and Joy Boy and how Luffy
and Blackbeard tie into all of it.
Now the Gorosei that gets revealed in chapter
1073 is this guy here with the white locks
and the massive scar across the left side
of his face.
His name is Saint Jay Garcia Saturn.
A name that truly no one expected, because
you wont believe how much information we can
pull from just this name.
I promise, you’re gonna love this.
The first thing we can deduce, based on the
saint title, is that the Gorosei truly are
celestial dragons themselves.
This was only revealed very recently.
For the longest time it was believed that
the Gorosei were actually lower in authority
than the average celestial dragons, who were
simply in charge of running the world while
the nobles could enjoy their luxurious life.
However during the Reverie arc, it was revealed
that the Gorosei are nobles themselves, with
much more power than someone like this guy,
who Luffy punched in the slave auction house.
This Gorosei, Saturn, seems to be from a family
called Jay Garcia, which surprisingly is only
the second world noble family name we have
heard in the story next to the don quixote
family.
And so we can see, that the celestial dragons
seem to have a somewhat Spanish theme to their
names.
The Don Quixote Family and the Jay Garcia
family.
Now Don Quixote is of course based on the
famous book character chasing wind mills,
but Jay Garcia doesn’t immediately ring
a bell.
That is, unless you are into Rock music.
Because Jay Garcia was the guitarist and singer
of the rock band ‘Grateful Dead’.
And to be honest, there is quite a lot of
similarity between him and Saturn.
But he’s not the only inspiration for this
Gorosei.
Now, in case you don’t know, all 5 of the
Gorosei are probably inspired by famous politicians
of the past.
The bold one with glasses is most likely based
on the indian revolutionary Mahatma Gandhi.
THe guy with the birthmark and the giant mustache
is based on the last sovjet president Mikhail
Gorbachev.
The guy with the ridiculously long beard looks
very similar to the japanese politician Itagaki
Taisuke.
The blond guy, who looks like Sanji’s long
lost uncle, is based on a young Abraham Lincoln.
And finally, saint Jay Garcia Saturn looks
like Karl Marx.
Don’t worry this will all make sense in
a moment.
Now all of these figures represent very different
political ideologies and all of them had their
flaws, but what unites all of them at least
from a historical perspective, is that they
are all associated with giving people more
freedom.
Lincoln is known for ending slavery in the
US, Gandhi ended British Colonial Rule in
India, Marx' fundamental idea, that was later
strongly misused by multiple regimes, was
the theory of liberty, stating that the freedom
of the people is the most important right,
that should not be exploited and controlled
by those with power and money.
Gorbachov was the last president of the Soviet
Union, who with his ideas of glasnost and
perestroika (openness and restructuring) promoted
democratic thinking and liberty in Eastern
Europe that ultimately led to the collapse
of the Soviet Union.
And finally Itagaki was leader of the Freedom
and People's Rights Movement and involved
with the founding of the first democratic
political party in Japan.
Which makes us wonder: Either Oda-sensei is
being very ironic by basing the authoritarian
rulers of the world on people fighting for
freedom.
Or there is something more to this.
As this chapter proves: There definitely is.
We’ll get to the really crazy part in just
a second.
There is really only a handful of things we
know ab out the Gorosei for sure.
Surprisingly, even though, they are the 5
most powerful people in the story, only answering
to the secret ruler Imu, they were only introduced
in chapter 233 of one piece.
They have full control over the Marines and
all the cypher pole agencies.
In fact Rob Lucci’s CP0 serves only them.
Which makes Stussy’s role as a double agent
even more interesting.
I wonder what information she might have overheard
from the five elders that she could share
with the straw hats.
We also know that the Gorosei are fully aware
of the true history and what happened during
the void century.
And there is even the very popular theory,
that all 5 of them are actually from the void
century themselves.
Former Kings of the 20 kingdoms that created
the world government who have been granted
immortality.
The Gorosei have also conducted a number of
great cleansings over time, whenever a new
threat to the world government’s rule has
popped up.
But one thing we could only speculate about
so far was their actual physical power.
As celestial dragons, it would seem likely,
that the Gorosei have enjoyed a life of luxury
without pain and suffering, like all the other
world nobles.
However, not only do they not wear the same
goofy looking space suits as the other nobles,
but they also seem to have battle experience.
The bald Gorosei is wielding a sword, that
many believe to be the Shodai Kitetsu, the
supreme grade version of Zoro’s sandai Kitetsu
sword or the nidai kitetsu that we saw in
Wano.
The guy who looks like Saji’s uncle looks
extremely fit as well and Saint Jay Garcia
Saturn has a large scar across his face.
So could the Gorosei be hiding some truly
powerful abilities?
I think with the reveal of Saturn’s name,
there is a really high probability that the
Gorosei can not only fight, but that they
are 5 of the 7 most powerful forces in One
Piece.
Manu, how in the world can you say that so
confidently when we only have one name?
Well I was getting to that jeez.
So, the first thing you probably noticed about
the name saturn is that it is a planet.
Duh.
This of course is interesting, because the
planets are named after roman gods, who again
are based on greek gods.
And as you already know, the 3 ancient weapons
are all named after a greek god and thus after
a planet: Pluton is Pluto, Uranus is the planet
Uranus and Poseidon is the Greek version of
Neptune.
Those are the last 3 planets in our solar
system.
Well at least they were when Oda started writing
one piece.
Pluto has not quite survived since then as
a planet.
Now if you know your planets using whatever
memorization phrase YOU learned in school,
you will know that saturn is the next planet
in line.
Now, coincindence you could say.
But first of all, those don’t exist, especially
not in One Piece.
But check out this: There are 9 planets.
3 of them are ancient weapons, one is earth
itself, which leaves us with 5 remaining planets
for 5 of the Gorosei.
Saturn, Jupiter, Mars, Venus an Mercury.
And suddenly the japanese word Gorosei makes
a lot more sense.
It used to be translated as the five elder
stars.
however the kanji for Star also means planet.
In other words, the Gorosei are actually the
five elder planets.
So by revealing just ONE SINGLE NAME, Oda
seems to tease all of the Gorosei’s individual
powers.
And there are actually 2 options for what
those powers are.
Number one are based the roman gods.
We know that Poseidon is the god of the sea,
and the ancinet weapon Poseidon, Shirahoshi
has powers that are connected to the sea.
Pluton, which is hidden inside the vulcano
on Wano seems to have powers connected to
the underworld like Pluto and Uranus, is speculated
to be connected to the sky, just like the
god of heaven.
Going with that logic, Saint Saturn could
have the powers of the god Saturn, the god
of time.
Jupiter, who is Zeus in Greek, is the god
of thunder.
Mars is the god of war.
Venus is the goddess of love.
And mercury or hermes in Greek is the messenger
god and god of trickery.
All of these would could be plausable powers
for the Gorosei.
HOWEVER.
I would argue that these gods aren’t actually
related to their powers at all.
The god of thunder to me sounds more like
Enel.
The god of war doesn’t really make sense.
Love to me is Boa Hancock.
And being a messanger sounds like a pretty
lame power to me.
Instead, I’d like to argue, that these are
not the Gorosei’s powers, but rather their
roles as heads of the government.
Mercury would be in charge of communication
and messaging, be it with the Marines, Cypther
Pole or people like Shanks.
Mars would be the Gorosei in charge of war.
He would be the Gorosei who was organizing
the war at marineford for example.
Jupiter I personally think would be the Gorosei
in charge of using the ancient weapon uranus.
After all it looks like the world government
used it to destroy an entire island just a
few chapters ago.
And Saturn, our Gorosei in this chapter, would
be in charge of anything related to time and
history.
so it would only make sense that he is the
guy who is coming for Vegapunk, who has all
the lost knowledge from the ancient kingdom,
that was gathered by the researchers on Ohara.
As for Venus and love, I have no idea what
that would be about honestly.
That’s a bit of a hole in that theory.
Maybe Oda took her as the god of prosperity
and not love and it’s the Gorosei in charge
of finances or something.
Now, if the gods aren’t the true powers
of the Gorosei, what is?
Let me flex my japanese skills a little bit
for this.
There are specific kanji for each of the planets.
Pluto has the kanji for darkness, the same
as Rayleigh’s dark king title by the way.
Uranus has the kanji for sky and neptune has
the kanji for the ocean.
The are kind of in their own category.
The 5 planets connected to the 5 elders share
a different category of symbols.
They are the 5 traditional elements: Fire,
Wood, Water, Earth and Metal.
Mars has the kanji for fire, kasei. Mercury
has the kanji for water, suisei.
Jupiter is wood, mokusei.
Venus is metal, Kinsei.
And Saturn is Earth.
Dosei.
I think that these 5 elements make way more
sense for the Gorosei’s ture powers than
the greek gods.
Fire, Wood, Water, Earth and Metal could be
versions of devil fruits or some other sort
of special ability, comparable to the ancient
weapons.
But if you think we’re done.
We’re just getting started.
The best part is what comes next.
Because the 5 traditional chinese elements
aren’t alone.
this entire ancient system is known as the
doctrine of Yin-Yang and the Five Elements.
In other words the 5 elements surround the
yin and yang, the dark and the light that
bring balance to the universe.
So next to the 5 Gorosei, we have a force
of light and a force of dark that keeps the
balance in the universe.
I wonder, have we ever heard anything related
to light or dark in one piece?
hmm.
In the unlikely case you still haven’t caught
on yet, let me show you this.
This is one normal week in a japanese calendar.
You’ll notice that 5 of the 7 days of the
week have the same Kanji as the 5 planets
slash the 5 elements: Tuesday is fire, mars.
Wednesday is water, mercury.
Thursday is wood, jupiter.
Friday is Metal, Venus and Saturday is Earth,
Saturn.
The two remaining days are, you guessed it,
sunday and monday.
The day of the sun and the day of the moon.
Same in japanese.
Sunday has the kanji for the sun and monday
has the kanji for the moon.
Yin and Yang.
Darkness and light.
The five elements.
Also I’m really grateful to Oda.
Thanks to One Piece I know finally understand
the logic behind both the weekdays AND the
planets in Japanese.
So, the sun part of this diagram is pretty
easy to fill I think.
That’s of course the Sun God.
Nika.
This is how the Gorosei are directly connected
to both Joy boy and Luffy.
The Moon part on the other hand could be 2
people i think.
Either it’s blackbeard, the kid who never
sleeps.
The dark opposite to Luffy and the kid that
was crying under the moon.
Or it is Imu, the secret ruler of the world.
The person who defeated Joy Boy and the ancient
kingdom.
The darkness that balances Luffy’s light.
This makes sense on so many levels.
Why Luffy’s devil fruit is so important.
What it means for Luffy to have become Joy
Boy.
Why Shanks, who cares about the balance of
the world was meeting with the Gorosei.
Why Blackbeard is the polar opposite to Luffy.
And this system might also tell us a little
bit about what happened during the void century.
For instance, it could mean that the Gorosei
once all ruled over different planets.
Or it could mean that the Gorosei, Imu and
Joy boy were once allies, that created a balance
across the world until Imu decided to betray
Joy Boy to break that balance.
Or it could mean that it will take both Luffy
and Blackbeard, the reincarnations of Joy
Boy and Rocks D Xebec together in order to
bring balance back to the world and take down
Imu who broke that balance.
That might also explain why the Gorosei are
modeld after politicians who are known for
bringing people freedom.
Maybe they are actually a force for the good,
the 5 gods waiting for the sun and the moon
gods to return to bring back balance to the
universe.
Which would also explain why Shanks would
work with them.
I was puzzling most of this together while
writing this script, so if you want a follow
up video on this where i have more time to
think about it, let me know by subscribing
to the channel.
And here is last week’s review!
Make sure to check that out too!
THanks for watching.